I'm Scott Jurek and I'm an
ultra-marathoner and today we're gonna
be talking about injury prevention I
love pushing myself to the edge and when
I'm injured I'm not able to train I'm
not able to race and so avoiding
injuries but then once they do occur
making sure that I recover is paramount
to my success there are a few things I
usually bring in my pack from a
first-aid standpoint there's not one set
first aid kit out there it's really
important that you start thinking about
how long am i out there how far away
from help am I and that's gonna be
dictating what type of first-aid
supplies you need one of the most common
injuries on the trailer blisters you
really want to start treating them early
on into a run or hike to prevent the
blisters you want to avoid the abrasion
I like to use on petroleum jelly which
just kind of helps keep the toes the
skin moving smoothly between the sock I
commonly will include some moleskin
or some of the fancier added blister
prevention tapes and cushions that are
out there just try to figure out you
know what kind of conditions are you
gonna be in and what's gonna be best for
your feet another common injury is the
ankle sprain
treating an ankle sprain initially
involves compression and compression can
come in different forms I commonly will
have a compression sock or sleeve that
it can put over taping can be pretty
complicated so the nice thing with an
ankle brace that has support around it
with straps will create the same type of
tension and support without the
complications of okay how do I tape this
ankle if you have a cold creek or a cold
lake by you getting the ankle in some
cold water to kind of bring down the
swelling can be really key to making the
comfort level a lot more manageable and
get you back to the trailhead or maybe
continue on if you notice that pain is
like a dull ache you're probably okay
you know pushing through that if it's
more of a searing that's probably not
the pain too much through
another common issue out on the trail is
dehydration when the signs of
dehydration start first and foremost you
want to start drinking water if you
haven't been incorporating salt or
electrolytes I would highly recommend
that you bring some of those with you we
lose a lot of electrolytes and sweat
finding that happy balance between
injury recovery and performance is
probably like the ultimate goal of any
athlete or anybody trying to push their
body a little bit harder and when you
find that balance you're gonna be able
to push your body further than you ever
thought you could
[Music]